james braddock and his children are
about to take their first ever rapid
flow tests
and they're doing it in the comfort of
their home i'm going to go into your
mouth
wait do you not do it with the other bit
the furry bit yeah
yeah okay
it's what they and anyone else living
with school going children will be
entitled to do
twice a week into the letter s
yeah so you're gonna squeeze three drops
as they wait for their results a chance
to catch up it was a little bit
uncomfortable like when i went on my
nose but apart from that it was fine i
think it's the time consuming thing with
the with the children that's going to be
more of a pain really um and
not so much with the oldest one but the
youngster
that could be an issue eight-year-old
seb has a reason to be cautious
well once i had a bait being up my nose
and
it was so uncomfortable the new measures
apply to anyone in a household or
support bubble with a child
or young person who goes to college
primary or secondary school in england
children will take their first three
tests at school and after that
they'll be able to collect them from
there and take them home
everyone else in the household will
either have to collect them from work
pick them up from one of these local
covid testing sites or order them online
the government hopes home testing for
families will help control the spread of
coronavirus when schools reopen next
week
macclesfield head teacher emmanuel
botway says it can't be the only
solution
the crucial thing is that this is seen
as being part of a range of measures
you know so we will still need to
socially distance there will still need
to be bubbles we will still be
encouraging
youngsters and teachers to stay away if
they have symptoms
the tests have been criticized as
ineffective with claims mass
testing missed people with early
infections and there are accusations
that the government has a huge stock
it now somehow needs to shift but
experts say it's a step
in the right direction it's a really
good way of having a red light test
saying
this child or this adult appears to be
infectious
they're the ones that should be excluded
from society public health test is
talking about risk mitigation it's not
about being a hundred percent perfect
all the time
the products results are in in just
under 20 minutes
both come back negative oh if you've got
zach i've got um
a line at sea let's see relief
a feeling they hope they can carry on
having twice a week
for months to come without covered sadia
chowdhury sky news
in cheshire